when's the last time you smoked weed
tonight I'll blue zero so now you're
trying to think I smelled weed right now
you're being placed under rest for
operating while intoxicated okay I'm not
intoxicated the man seen here wasn't
charged with any crime but he's still in
the middle of legal battle why he put
this body camera footage online and cops
say he defamed them in the comments
taten galanakis wasn't drunk or high the
night two Newton Iowa officers pulled
him over on suspicion of driving Under
the Influence after he blew a zero on a
breathalyzer they asked if he'd been
smoking weed but a drug test came back
negative too galanakis was so frustrated
he posted the video online criticized
the officer in social media posts and
even filed a wrongful arrest suit
against them cops hit back with their
own suit arguing they were defamed on
YouTube and other social media sites
while the defamation suit is still
moving forward a judge threw out many of
the claims and affirmed galanakis had a
right to publish the body cam footage
Americans have broad rights to criticize
the cops even if the cops don't like it